hey what's up everyone it's Warren
and it seems like there may have been
some evidence for time travel staring us
right in the face this whole entire time
and this comes from the Avengers in-game
page on IMDB so if we pop over to the
Avengers in-game page you can see at the
top right here it says Avengers in-game
full cast and crew we have the Russo
brothers right here who are the
directors writing credits that
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
are main guys right here Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby and jim Starlin who has
characters appearing in the movie as
well and if you scroll down a little bit
we can see the cast so right off the bat
we see the main cast the Avengers that
survived the snap and some of the
Avengers that didn't obviously the
majority of people think that the
Avengers that did not survive the snap
will be back in some way or form and of
course I agree with that but if we
scroll down we can start to see some
pretty interesting things if we scroll
down enough we can start to see
characters that were not in Avengers
infinity war but are listed to appear in
Avengers endgame as you can see on the
IMDB cast list we can see the ancient
one you can also see Brock rumlow slash
crossbones and right below him is Harley
keener from Iron Man 3 we also have
Katherine Langford whose role is
currently unknown there are two main
assumptions of who her character could
be in avengers endgame one of them is
Hawkeye's daughter and although many
people believe that she could in fact be
playing Hawkeye's daughter a lot of
people also believe that Hawk guy's
entire family fell victim to the snap
and another character that people
believe she could be playing is an older
version of Scott Lang's daughter Cassie
Lang but Catherine Lankford is
considerably older than the actress that
plays Cassie Lang and we just saw Cassie
Lang not too long before the snap in
ant-man and the wasp
so if she is considerably older the
timeline would have to end up in the
future somehow and since we know from
the Avengers in-game trailer it's not
going to start five years into the
future that means time travel is
involved somehow but let's take a look
at some other characters the ancient one
and Brock rumlow / crossbones they're
both dead how are they in Avengers end
game but if we scroll down just a little
bit more we can see a character whose
title is
seventies car girl number one and just a
little bit below that a character whose
title is 1970s scientists slash lab
worker so the seventies characters
confirmed that we will be in a scene
that is taking place in two seventy
somehow and the fact that we are seeing
dead characters names appear on the cast
list for a vendor's endgame means that
we'll see them somehow so how could they
appear in Avengers in game well it seems
like there are three main ways that this
could happen
one is flashbacks to is Tony Stark's
barf technology and three is time travel
and out of all of these three options
time travel is the only one that really
makes sense for all of these characters
flashbacks don't let you see into the
future so if there's an older version of
Hawkeye's daughter or Scott Lang's
daughter flashbacks would not let us see
her and the same goes for barf
technology barf technology would not
allow somebody to look into the future
only look into past events that are from
their memories but time travel makes
sense as a way to see all of these
characters that are listed here you
could travel back to the 70s which is
where we would see those seventies
characters listed they could travel back
in time and try to change events of the
past which is where we may see
crossbones and Wong could even travel
back in time to get advice from the
ancient one and to learn more about the
time stone but this also allows the
Avengers to go forward in time which
makes sense because if ant-man goes out
of a time vortex and ends up in the
future he could go and search for his
daughter and if she's not a victim of
the snap he could talk to her and find
out what happened this is just more
evidence pointing to the fact that the
Avengers are going to have to time
travel somehow an Avengers endgame and
although this cast list is not a
confirmation it does give us even more
hints that time travel will be involved
in avengers endgame so let me know your
thoughts on this and these characters
that are listed to appear in a vendor's
endgame in the comments down below do
you think time travel will be involved
or do you think it will be something
else let me know your thoughts and I'm
still giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet if you would like to enter the
giveaway for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]